voilà sortie demain jamel debbouze vous
vouliez réveiller les consciences avec
ce film avant même sa sortie en salles
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
que le but est atteint
tout le monde en parle jacques chirac va
annoncer des mesures sur les pensions et
on pouvait pas rêver mieux
on pouvait pas rêver mieux que la classe
politique soit touché par sa fille aussi
un formidable d'autant plus que quand on
l'a fait on a fait pour eux et que
aujourd'hui la plupart de ses collègues
sont bloqués dans des foyers sonacotra
je trouve que c'est c'est la moindre des
choses qu'on se prend ce qu'on se rende
compte de leur situation
vous l'avez senti vous l'engouement par
exemple lors de cette projection avec
jacques chirac on a vu des photos on
avait l'impression qui s'est mal passé
quelques chevaux ce samedi avec le chef
de l'état est très impressionné par ces
images je fais pas le malin
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce soir là
parce que écouté très franchement moi gt
gt gt touché par parle par le fait de
les voir aussi touché là il trichait pas
ce soir là ils ont été ils ont été
sensibles à ce film est la preuve
il ya des mesures qui seront
certainement prises en tout cas on
attend le communiqué avec impatience
demain on va vous entendre géologie la
paix d'abord un mot monsieur l'alec vous
vous avez vu le film on vous a vu à
cannes sur les marchés ce que vous
l'avez aimé ce film sur film et trace
notre vie
c'est un film qu'il a un grand sens et
un matin il y avait pas d'oubli vous
avez reconnu ce que vous avez vécu vous
l'avez retrouvé dans ce film exactement
est ce que vous vous avez souffert du
manque de reconnaissance
oui ça veut dire y'a en 1941 si lointain
que ça commençait déjà là et qui avait
le sol vis-à-vis de nous ça veut dire
qu'on appelait indigènes et les
européens en avait 25 centimes et les
autres gobelins comme centimes ça
commençait déjà là il y avait déjà de la
bagarre à l'intérieur de la caserne m et
en même temps l'union naturellement
dispersée et tout ce qui était sa
meilleure c'est le régiment qu'on
appelait du 5e régiment de tirailleurs
algériens avec écart maison carrée et
après nous ont refoulé naturellement
comme moi j'ai pu refouler à oran
et vous avez l'impression que ce film va
peut-être dit long raccommodé cet oubli
ou pas peut-être c'est sûr bon sami
bouajila est ce que vous en parliez vous
de ces tirailleurs avec vos parents ou
avec vos grands parents et vos arrières
grands parents
absolument pas jamais ou de manière très
évasive mais on n'en parlait pas dans
votre famille n'ont absolument pas
pourquoi je ne sais pas
sincèrement je ne sais pas maintenant
c'est pas c'était pas la même chose chez
toutes les familles je crois que chez
rachid
ils ont parlé ils avaient un lien avec
avec un de leurs ancêtres qui avait fait
la première guerre déjà nous simplement
parce que c'est une famille à s'exprimer
et que ce sont des petites gens pour la
plupart qui sont analphabètes et qui et
puis parce qu'on parle de manque de
mémoire de la france de reconnaissance
de la france mandat l'impression que
dans les familles cwi sujet l'année
passée c'est qu'ils sont tombés dans une
double amnésie je pense c'est que la
france n'en parlaient pas et pour cause
c'est un passé douloureux
tout tout tout tout l'époque coloniale
et puis au maghreb une fois que les pays
du maghreb ont pris leur indépendance
c'était assez mal vu que là bas on parle
de ses soldats arabes engagés sous
l'armée française mais il faut se
rappeler qu'à ce moment là c'était le
temps des colonies
et qu'on n'en est pas encore à la guerre
d'indépendance c'est à dire que les gens
n'avaient pas forcément le choix
et voilà mais du coup ils sont tombés
sous le coup d'une double amnésie moi je
voudrais simplement précisé que pour
notre part le moteur de départ juste que
je veux dire c'est que tous à nous
échapper que hong hao à aucun moment on
a prémédité l'ampleur que ça pouvait
prendre automne vous aviez envie non
l'envié était là de tout le temps vous
savez monsieur les mots qui sont dits
dans ce film les les vexations qu'ils
ont pu vivre et et le message de fond
qui est véhiculé dans ce film nous par
modestie je me permettrai pas de venez
nous on le porte de longue date c'est
quelqu'un est ce qu'on a comme ça
inconsciemment vous la connaissez cette
histoire mal malheureusement est revu
quant à rachid bouchareb m'a donné
l'opportunité de jouer ce personnage
d'abord j'ai été séduit par le scénario
ça m'intéressait dit que tu connais son
taf héééé par le propos forcément mais
au-delà de ça j'étais fier de pouvoir
donner des héros qui quitte à mon petit
frère qui nous ressemblent qu'on puisse
identifier parce que nous on en a jamais
eu
on n'a jamais eu ses repères là on n'a
jamais eu et des héros sur lequel
verront cosy me suis fait ne serait-ce
que ceux projetés il héros iron tout
simplement de beau gosse
pour commencer dès auront beau gosse le
plein de vie c'est vrai qu'on a pas
l'habitude on les voit dans l'avare aux
parcours c'est par des écueils
mais rarement comme ça ddd héros avec un
objectif noble et digne
c'est vrai jamel debbouze simplement
petites choses que vous avez accepté de
ne pas être payés sauf sur les éventuels
bénéfices du film we donc c'est un
engagement vraiment mais ce film était
est indispensable pour moi il est il et
il est utile d'abord si jamais elle est
devenu sérieux pas lui parler sérieux
non pas du tout que ce soit la dass je
commençais pas mal chauffés pas ce que
je vais faire le tour et qui sait vous
savez très bien tomber c'est bien aussi
là le sujet demande à ce qu'on a à ce
qu'ont apporté à ce que à ce que ça soit
oui non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que il est indispensable que ce que ce
genre d'histoire soir à que ce soir à
compter d'abord sur le plan
cinématographique
on n'a pas l'habitude de voir ce genre
de films au cinéma en un film épique
avec l'émotion d'un reggae vraies scènes
de guerre 6 a annoncé par des fils
d'immigrés s'est mis en scène par un
parent à fils d'immigré ça c'est ça
prouve que la france avance et alors le
bon sens pour les petits enfants les
arrières petits enfants des tirailleurs
c'est important aujourd'hui ceux qui
sont dans les banlieues qui sont
toujours pas forcément bien vu qu'ils
ont ils peuvent avoir des soucis mais
c'est indispensable quand les hommes
politiques passent leur temps à créer
des clans il est indispensable que qui
est ce genre de choses qui existent pour
pour rassembler réconcilier
on fait partie intégrante de la france
mais on a on a une histoire commune ont
fait partie du de l'album familial
nationale vous avez vu la une du nouvel
observateur cette semaine n'ont jamais l
on l'a eu en mode inquiet le drapeau
plus proche
pourquoi j'aime la france mais voit
n'est pas parce que vous êtes devenu un
symbole
ça fait plaisir un porte parole un
symbole ça vous plaît non mais moi je
suis pas ni assistante sociale ni porte
drapeau mais c'est vrai que j'aime la
france pour tout ce qu'elle m'a apporté
pour les joies pour mes pelle et j'ai
envie de mourir sur ce sol et gg
j'aimerais juste qu'on ne prenne le plus
en considération ce qui paraît qu'ils
vont frapper sur la pièce doisneau
ça c'est que ce sera l'étape suivante
est ce qu'on en pense il a dû oublier
les sacs et ben merci beaucoup à vous
trois jonas indigènes qui sort demain en
salles merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite
c'est vous pouvez y aller mais sinon si
vous attendez 30 secondes ce sera
complètement terminée mais mettez vous
assaillent et jamel alors il lui avait
dit qu'il était sérieux je vais parler
un peu vite voilà voulait faire la fin
ouais juste tourner comme des divas
comme on aurait pu s'y journal tout de
suite moment la météo à la réunion les
chevaux voilà 50 93 rue lauriston un
téléfilm avec samuel le bihan et michel
blanquer salue au passage
aliou mané valait 1 à demain mais bon tu
m'auras vu aussi à barcelone et à dubaï
merci à tous
tout